The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: I'm determined
to tell you something
about the convolution rule.
I just get close to it, but
haven't quite got there.
And actually, I'd like
to say something also
about why convolution
is so important.
I mentioned here a paper about
images in deep learning by--
it has three authors, and
these are two of them.
Maybe you recognize
Hinton's name.
He's originally English.
He was in San Diego
for quite a few years,
and now he's in Canada.
So Toronto and Montreal are big
centers now for deep learning.
And he's really one of the
leaders, and so is Sutskever.
So maybe you know that the sort
of progress of deep learning
can often be measured in
these competitions that
are held about every
year for how well does--
people design and execute
a whole neural net.
And this was a
competition about images.
So that is really demanding,
because, as I said last time,
an image has so many
samples, so many
pixels that the computational
problem is enormous.
And that's when you would go to
convolution neural nets, CNN,
because a convolutional net
takes fewer weights, because
of the same weight as
appearing along diagonals.
It doesn't need a full
matrix of weights,
just one top row of weights.
Anyway, so this is one
of the historical papers
in the history of deep learning.
I'll just read a
couple of sentences.
We trained-- so this
is the abstract.
We trained a large deep
convolutional neural network.
I'll just say that it ran
for five days on two GPUs.
So it was an enormous
problem, as we'll see.
So we trained a large
deep network, CNN,
to classify 1.2 million
high res images in ImageNet.
So ImageNet is a source
of millions of images.
And on the test data, they--
well, the last sentence
is maybe a key.
We entered a variant
of this model
in the competition,
2012 competition,
and we achieved a winning top
five test error rate of 15%
compared to 26% for
the second place team.
So 15% error.
They got 26% was the best that
the rest of the world did.
And so that-- and when
he shows the network,
you realize what's gone into it.
It has convolution layers,
and it has some normal layers,
and it has max pooling layers
to cut the dimension down
a little bit.
And half the samples go on
one GPU and half another.
And at certain points,
layers interconnect
between the two GPUs.
And so to reduce overfitting--
you remember that.
It's a key problem is
to reduce overfitting
in the fully connected layers.
Those are the ordinary layers
with full weight matrices.
We employed a recently developed
regularization called dropout.
So dropout is a tool which,
if you're in this world, you--
I think Hinton
proposed it, again,
by seeing that it worked.
It's just a careful dropout
of some of the data.
It reduces the amount
of data, and it
doesn't harm the problem.
So the neural network has
60 million parameters.
60 million.
With 650,000 neurons, five
convolutional layers, and three
fully connected layers.
I just mention this.
If you just Google these
two names on the web,
this paper would come up.
So we're talking about
the real thing here.
Convolution is something
everybody wants to understand.
And I'd like to--
since I've started
several days ago,
and I'd like to remember
what convolution means.
Let me-- so if I
convolve two vectors
and I look for the k-th
component of the answer,
the formula is I add up
all the c's times d's where
are index i plus j adds to k.
Why do you do such a thing?
Because c might be
represented by a polynomial,
say x plus c Nx to
the N. And d might
be represented by another 1d 1x
plus dm x to the m, let's say.
And convolution arises when
I multiply those polynomials.
Because for a typical--
and then collect terms.
Because a typical power
of x, say x to the k,
the coefficients are--
well, how do we get x to
the k in multiplying these?
I multiply c0 times a dk.
Somewhere in here would
be a dk x to the k.
So a c0 times a dk would
give me an x to the k term.
And a c1 times--
everybody sees this coming now?
c1 has an x in it already.
So over there, we would look
at dk minus 1 with one less x.
So it would be c1 dk minus 1.
This is just what you do when
you multiply a polynomial.
And the point is that the
way we recognize those terms
is that the exponents 0 and k,
the exponents 1 and k minus 1,
always add to k.
So that's where this
formula comes from.
We take a c times a d hiding
behind our cx to the i and a dj
x to the j and when i plus
j is k, this is x to the k.
And that's the term
we're capturing.
So this is the
coefficient of that term.
And let me write it as a
slightly different way, where
you actually see even more
clearly convolution operating.
So j is k minus i, right?
So it's the sum of cidj, but
the j has to be k minus i.
So this is the way to
remember the formula
for the coefficients in c
star d in the convolution.
You look at c's times d's.
It's a form of multiplication.
It comes from ordinary
multiplication of polynomials.
And when you collect
terms, you're collecting c,
the i-th c and the k minus id,
and you're taking all possible
i's.
So it's a sum over
all possible i's
there to give you
the k-th answer.
Well, just to see
if you got the idea,
what would be the
convolution of two functions?
Suppose I have a
function f of x.
And I want I convolve that
with a function g of x.
OK.
And notice that I have
not circled this symbol.
So I'm not doing
periodic convolution.
I'm just doing
straightforward convolution.
So what are we going to have
in the case of two functions?
What would that mean, a
convolution of functions?
I'm in parallel here with a
convolution of two vectors.
So think of these now
have become functions.
The case component has become--
really, I should
say f star g at x.
That's really the
parallel to this.
So let me.
So I'm telling you
the answer at x.
Here I told you the answer at k.
The k-th component
looks like that.
What does the x value
of the convolution look
like for functions?
OK, I'm just going to do this.
I'm going to do
the same as this.
Instead of summing,
what will I do?
Integrate.
Instead of c sub i,
I'll have f of x.
The index i is changing over
to the continuous variable x.
And now g instead of dk
minus i, what do I have here?
So it's the k minus i component.
That will go to--
let me just write it down--
t minus x.
So in this translation, f
is being translated to c.
Or sorry, f corresponds to c.
g corresponds to d.
k corresponds to x.
Oh no, sorry. i
corresponds to x.
And k minus i
corresponds to t minus x.
So k corresponds to t.
This would be the
convolution of two functions.
Oh, it's a function of t.
Bad notation.
The t is sort of
the amount of shift.
See, I've shifted g.
I've reversed it.
I've flipped it and shifting
it by different amounts t.
It's what you have in a filter.
It's just also always
present in signal processing.
So that that would
be a definition.
Or I could, if you like, if you
want an x variable to come out,
let me make an x variable come
out by exchanging t and x.
So this would be x minus t dt.
I like that, actually,
a little better.
And it's the integral over
t minus infinity to infinity
if our functions were
on the whole line.
So there will be a
convolution rule for that.
This will connect to the Fourier
transform of the two functions.
Over here, I'm connecting
it to the discrete Fourier
transform of the two functions.
And I've been making
the convolution cyclic.
So what does-- can
I add cyclic now?
This is ordinary convolution.
This is what you had
in the first lab,
I think, from Raj Rao.
The first lab, you
remember you had
to figure out how many
components the convolution
would have?
And you didn't make it cyclic.
So a cyclic convolution,
if this has n components
and this has n components,
then the convolution
has n components.
Because keeping n
is the key number
there, the length of the period.
And similarly,
over here, if f is
2 pi periodic and
g is 2 pi periodic,
then we might want to do
a periodic convolution
and bring it--
get an answer that also
has 2 pi period 2 pi.
So you could compute
the convolution
of sine x with cos
x, for example.
OK, let's stick with vectors.
So what's the deal
when I make it cyclic?
When I make it cyclic, then
in this multiplication,
I really should use--
I've introduced w as
that instead of x.
So cyclic.
x becomes this number w, which
is e to the 2 pi i over n
and has the property
then that w to the n-th
is 1 so that all vectors
of length greater than n
can be folded back using this
rule to a vector of length n.
So we get a cyclic guy.
So how does that
change the answer?
Well, I only want k
going from 0 to n minus 1
in the cyclic case.
I don't want infinitely
many components.
I've got to bring
them back again.
And let me just say
what the rule would be.
You just ask, say, i plus j.
You would look at that modulo n.
That's what a number theory
person would call it.
We only look at the remainder
when we divide by n.
So now the sums go only
from 0 to n minus 1,
and I only get an answer
from 0 to n minus 1.
Well, I've done
that pretty quickly.
That's if I wanted
to do justice to--
So the difference
between non-periodic.
So non-periodic and periodic
will be the difference
between--
so I have some number t0 on the
diagonals. t1, t2, t minus 1,
t minus 2, and so on.
Constant diagonals.
So the key name
there is Toeplitz.
And if it's periodic, then
I have, I'll say, c, c, c.
And then the next one will be
c1, c1, coming around to c1.
And c2 coming around.
So it's n by n period n.
So it's a circulant matrix.
N by N.
OK.
That's the big picture.
And I think in
that first lab, you
were asked to do the
non-circulant case.
Because that's the one where you
have to do a little patience.
What will be the length?
Yeah, what would be the
length of a non-circulant?
So not circulant.
Now, suppose the c
vector has p components
and the d vector
has q components.
How many components
in their convolution?
Shall I write that
question down?
Because that brings out
the difference here.
So if I have p, if c has P
components, d has q components,
then the convolution of
c and d has how many?
So I'm multiplying.
So it's really this corresponds
to a polynomial of degree
p minus 1, right?
Polynomials of degree p minus 1.
And this guy would
be degree q minus 1.
Degree q minus 1.
And when I multiply
them, what's the degree?
Just add.
And how many coefficients?
Well, one more I
have to remember
for that stupid 0 order term.
So this would have p plus
q minus 1 components.
So that would have
been the number
that you've somehow had to
work out in that first lab.
So that if this had n
components and this had n,
this would have 2n minus 1.
It's just what you
would have-- like you
say 3 plus x times 1 plus 2x.
In this case, p is 2, q is two,
two components, two components.
And if I multiply those, I get
3x and 6x is 7x and 2x squared.
And so I have 2 plus 2
minus 1 equals 3 components.
The constant x and x squared.
Yeah, clear, right.
Yeah, so that's not the--
that's what I would get if I
multiplied these matrices, if I
had a two diagonal
matrix, Toeplitz matrix,
times a two diagonal Toeplitz
matrix, that would give me
a three diagonal answer.
But if I am doing
it periodically,
I would only have two.
That 2x squared would
come back if I--
come back as a 2.
so I just have 5 plus 7x.
Right, good, good, good.
OK.
So that's a reminder
of what convolution is.
Cyclic and non-cyclic,
vectors and functions.
OK, then eigenvalues and
eigenvectors are the next step,
and then the convolution
rule is the last step.
So eigenvectors.
Eigenvectors of the circulant.
Of course, I can only
do square matrices.
So I'm doing the periodic case.
So the eigenvectors
are the columns
of the eigenvector matrix.
And I'm going to call
it F for Fourier.
So F is-- the first
eigenvector is all 1s.
An x eigenvector is
the fourth root of 1,
then the square root of
1, i6, i8, i fourth, i6,
and finally, 1 i
cubed i sixth i ninth.
OK, that's F. Those are the four
eigenvectors of the permutation
p and of any polynomial in p.
So my circulant is some
c0 i plus c 1p plus c
2p squared and c3 pq.
OK.
And finally, this is the step
we've been almost ready to do
but didn't quite do.
What are the eigenvectors--
what eigenvectors
are its eigenvectors?
So those are the
eigenvectors of p.
And now we have just
a combination of p's.
So I think the eigenvectors
I just multiply.
I take that same combination
of the eigenvectors.
Does that look right?
So sorry.
I'm sorry.
Its eigenvectors,
they're the columns of f.
The question I meant to ask
is what are its eigenvalues?
That's the key question.
What are the eigenvalues?
And I think that if I
just multiply F times c,
I get the eigenvalues
of the matrix C.
That's the beauty.
That's the nice formula.
If my matrix is just P alone,
then this is 0, 1, 0, 0,
and I get 1, i, i
squared, i cubed.
But if c is some other
combination of the p's, then I
take the same combination
of the eigenvectors to see--
yeah.
Do you see it?
So I'm claiming that I'll
get four eigenvalues of C
from this multiplication.
So of course, if
there's only c0,
then I only get c0, c0, c0, c0.
It's four times repeated.
But if it's this combination,
then that matrix multiplication
takes the same combination of--
this is a combination
of the eigenvectors.
And that gives us
the right thing.
OK.
Now I just have one more step
for this convolution rule,
and then I'm happy.
Really, the convolution
rule is stating what we--
it's stating a relation
between multiplication,
which we saw here, and
the convolution, which
we saw for the coefficients.
So the convolution rule is a
connection between multiplying
and convolution.
And so let me say what
that convolution rule is
and let me write it correctly.
So here I take a
cyclic convolution.
I'm dealing with
square matrices.
Everything is cyclic here.
And then I get--
if I multiply by F,
what do I have now?
What does that represent?
This was c and d,
and I convolve them.
So I got another
circulant matrix.
So up here, the multiplication
of matrices is C times D.
I want to connect multiplying
those matrices with convolving
the c's.
I want to make that connection.
And that connection is
the convolution rule.
So this would be the
eigenvalues of CD.
Let's just pause there.
Why am I looking at
the eigenvalues of CD?
Because if I do
that multiplication,
I get another Toeplitz
matrix, C times D.
And the polynomial-- the
coefficients associated
on the diagonals of C times
D are the coefficients
of the convolution.
So its diagonals come from
convolving c with d cyclically.
OK.
Now I want to find the same
eigenvalues in a second way
and match--
and the equation will
be the convolution rule.
So how can I find the
eigenvalues of CD?
Well, amazingly, they
are the eigenvalues
of C times the eigenvalues
of D. I'm going
to test this rule on 2 by 2.
So you'll see
everything happening.
So this is the main-- this is
the fact that I want to use.
Because C and D commute.
C and D commute.
They have the same eigenvectors.
And then the eigenvalues
just multiply.
So I can multiply.
I can get that in a second way
by taking the eigenvalues of c
and multiplying those
by the eigenvalues of d.
And I multiply
component by component.
I multiply the eigenvalue
for the all 1s vector
by the eigenvalue for
the all 1s vector.
Do you know this MATLAB command?
Component by component
multiplication?
This is an important one.
There's a guy's name is
also associated with that.
So that's a vector.
That's a vector.
And what comes out
of that operation?
If I have a vector
with three components.
So n is 3 here.
And I do point star or dot star.
I'm not sure what
people usually say.
Component by component, a three
component vector times a three
component vector, I get
a three component vector,
just like that.
So this is the convolution rule.
That's the convolution rule.
And the proof is the fact
that when matrices commute,
the eigenvalues of
the product are just
these eigenvalues times
these eigenvalues,
because they have the same--
the eigenvectors
are always the same
here for all these circulants.
So there's the convolution rule
that I can convolve and then
transform.
Or I can transform
separately and then multiply.
So I just maybe better
right that convolution rule.
Let's call it the C rule.
Convolve then transform by F.
Or transform separately by F.
And then multiply point one.
Element by element.
Component by component.
OK.
So that's the convolution rule.
And why is it sort of--
why is it so important?
Because transforming
by F, multiplying
by the Fourier matrix, is
extremely fast by the FFT.
So it's useful because of
the FFT, the Fast Fourier
Transform, to multiply.
Or to transform.
Whichever.
Equal to transform.
Multiply by F transform.
So it's the presence of
the FFT that makes this--
it gives us really two
different ways to do it.
In fact, which is
the faster way?
So we can produce the same
result this way or this way.
And if I don't count the cost
of-- if the cost of multiplying
by F is low, because I have
the FFT, which would you do?
Which would you do?
So let me just think aloud
before we answer that question,
and then we're good.
So my vectors have n components.
So one way I can do
is to do convolution.
How many steps is that?
If I take a vector
with n components
and I convolve with a
vector with n components,
how many little multiplications
do I have to do?
N squared, right?
Because each of the c's has
to multiply each of the d's.
So that takes N squared.
And Fourier is cheap.
It's N log N. Log to base 2.
So the left hand side
is effectively N cubed.
What about this one?
How many to do these two guys?
To find the Fourier transform
to multiply by the matrix F. OK,
those are fast again.
That's just I've got two
multiplications by F.
So that's 2 N log N. And
what's the cost of this?
I have a vector
with n components.
Dot star vector.
Another vector
with n components.
How many little
multiplications do I
have to do for a Hadamard
product or a component
by component product?
N, only n.
Plus N. Yeah, maybe I
should have made that plus.
I had two.
No, I had one N
log N. Plus it took
N squared to find that vector.
And then N log N. So it's
effectively N squared.
But this one where I do the
N log N twice and then it
only takes me N more.
So this is the fast way.
So if you wanted to
multiply two really big,
long integers, as you would want
to do in cryptography, if you
had two long integers, say,
of length 125, 126, 128
components, to
multiply those, you
would be better off
to separately take
the cyclic transform of
each of those 128 guys
and do it this way.
Take the transforms, do the
component by component product,
and then transform
back to get that.
The convolution rule
is what makes that go.
Oh, one more thought,
I guess, about all
this convolution stuff.
Suppose we're in 2D.
We have to think what is a
two dimensional convolution?
What does this become
in two dimensions?
Suppose we have functions.
So now I'm gonna do 2D
functions of x and y.
Periodic or not periodic.
But what's a convolution?
What's the operation we have
to do in two dimensions?
Well, it's a double
integral, of course.
t and u.
We would do f of t and u times
g of x minus ty minus u dtdu.
And that would
produce a function.
So I'm convolving a
function of x and y
with another
function of x and y.
And again, I'm looking for this.
This is the key to watch for.
x minus t.
y minus u.
That's the signal of a
convolution integral.
So that's what we
would have in 2D.
In general, So maybe
now my final thought
is to move to think about
two dimensional matrices
and their products and so on.
And this is why you need them.
Because if you have two
dimensional signals,
then the components
fit into a matrix.
And we just have to
operate in both dimensions.
So the key operation
in 2D is in MATLAB.
The MATLAB command that
you need to know to get--
if you know what you're doing in
1D and you want to do it in 2D,
the MATLAB command is Kron.
So imagine we have one
dimensional matrices A and B.
And so those are in 1D, and we
want to produce a natural two
dimensional matrix.
So these will be N
by N. And we want
the sort of natural
product, let me call it
K for Kron, which will be
N squared by N squared.
I want to create a 2D matrix
connected to an image that's
N in each direction.
So it has N squared pixels.
These are 1D signals,
and K is a 2D one.
And this K would be the--
this is the operation to know.
Given two one dimensional
n by n matrices,
Kron produces an N squared
by N squared matrix.
It's the operation to know.
So I'll just write it, and
if you know what Kron is,
then you know it
before I write it.
So I want to produce a big
matrix, N squared by N squared.
Somehow appropriately
multiplying these two guys.
And the appropriate way to do it
is to take a11 and multiply it
by B. So there, what do I have?
What size have I
got there already
just in that one corner?
N by N, right?
It's a number of times
an N by N matrix.
Then a12 times B. That's
another N by N matrix.
Up to a1N times
B. So I have now--
sorry, cap N.
So I have cap N
matrices in a row.
Each of those
matrices is N by N.
So that row has
length n squared.
And of course, the next row is--
I've allowed myself
to number from 1 to N,
but very often that numbering
should be 0 to n minus 1.
And finally on down here
down to an1 B to aNN B. So so
that's the N squared
by N squared matrix
that you would need to know.
For example, if you wanted to
do a two dimensional Fourier
transform, that would be--
yeah, so what would a two
dimensional Fourier transform
produce?
What matrix?
Is this the matrix you
would use for a 2D?
I haven't sort of got
started properly on 2D
Fourier transforms.
So would it be F times F?
So let me write down the
full name of this guy.
Kronecker.
So it's called the
Kronecker product.
It's just the
right thing to know
in moving from one
dimension to two dimensions.
For example.
Let me do an example.
Oops, that's full.
Have I got one board left?
Yeah.
So here's a standard matrix.
Call it A. 2s and minus 1s.
So that corresponds
to a second derivative
or actually minus a
second derivative.
Now, suppose I have
another, the same matrix,
corresponding to second
derivatives in the y direction.
Same.
And what I really
want to do is both.
I want to have a matrix
K that corresponds
to minus the second
in the x direction
minus the second in the y.
So this is the Laplace.
Laplacian.
Which is all over the place
in differential equations.
At a typical point, I
want to do minus one
of these, two of these minus
one of those in the x direction,
and I want to add
to that minus 1.
Now that 2 becomes a 4 and
minus 1 in the y direction.
So I'm looking for
the 2 by 2 matrix--
sorry, the two dimensional
matrix that takes--
that does that
five point scheme.
Five weights at each point.
It takes four of the--
on the diagonal and minus
1 on the four neighbors.
And the operation that
would do that would be you
would use Kron.
It wouldn't be Kron of
A B. That would just--
K of A B is not what I--
a Kron of A B is
not what I want.
Yeah, that would do one
and then the other one.
And then that would probably
produce nine non-zeroes.
I want something that adds here.
So I want Kron of A
times the identity.
That gives me the
two dimensional thing
for this part.
And then I'll add on Kron of I
B for the vertical derivative,
the derivatives in
the y direction.
So that's called
a Kronecker sum.
The other was a
Kronecker product.
So that would be a
This would be another
Kronecker product,
and the total is called
the Kronecker sum.
OK.
I wanted just to get
those notations out.
Because really,
Fourier transforming
is such a central operation
in all of applied math,
and especially in
signal processing.
OK, so I'm good for it today.
Let's see.
I've got one volunteer so
far to talk about a project.
Can I encourage an email from
anybody that doesn't-- you
don't have to be a superstar.
You're just willing to do it.
Tell us something about
what you've learned.
Get comments from the audience.
And 10 or 15 minutes is
all I'm thinking about.
OK, I'll let you send me an
email if you'd like to tell us
that and get some feedback.
OK, good.
So I'll see you Wednesday.
Thanks.